hey guys it's Kylie and Jordan here
Kylie Jenner and Jordan Woods are
longtime BFFs eighth-grade some are
going into high school but now a source
confirms to ET Jordan isn't staying at
Kylie's home following allegations she
may have hooked up with Khloe
Kardashian's beau Tristan Thompson our
source explained quote kylie is
extremely upset about everything that is
going on with Khloe and her best friend
Jordan Jordan is a sister to Kylie and
she's extremely shocked this could
happen as is the whole family
however our source says Kylie hasn't
made up her mind just yet quote Kylie
needs her space and also wants to
respect her sister Chloe the future of
their friendship hangs on the facts if
my true fans are wanna know personal
things first unraveled on Tuesday when a
source told DT Chloe and Tristan split
over trust issues all while multiple
reports surfaced with claims of a tryst
between Tristan and Jordan you have to
find the happy medium of keeping your
private life private
any person like you know it's just and
fans are busy tracking social media for
clues Kim Kardashian unfollow Jordan and
Tristan on Instagram Chloe liked a tweet
from a fan criticizing Tristan and
Jordan for the alleged incident
she also seemingly deleted photos with
Tristan from her Instagram I just want
to live my life and be happy
[Music]